joining us now Sheen fan leader Mary Lou
McDonald hi good morning thanks very
much on the program what do you make of
these strikes first of all
well I I heard just that that last
exchange between yourself and passion
you said like who's responsible for
deaths should they should the strike
action go ahead just remember nursing
staff emergency crew save lives every
single day and they've been put under
the most unbearable pressure and the NHS
certainly in the north of Ireland we
have a full-blown Health crisis uh we
need more investment we need more
capacity and above all else we need now
a government that will sit down
with the nurses with their unions with
people and to be reasonable recognize
the scale of the crisis and then strike
a reasonable deal I I just think it's
unconscionable given that that strike
action is looming that any responsible
government would say this is our offer
that's it this far and no further when
it's obvious to everybody the incredible
work that's done within the Health
Service but also the gaping need for
more resources and as Pat said to bring
people into the nursing profession
nursing Midwifery and other medical
professions and to keep them there
there's a recruitment and a retention
issue and if you have a system that's In
Perpetual strain on In Perpetual crisis
of course professionals at some point
are going to say enough is enough and
unfortunately walk away and that really
puts lives in danger today's the
deadline for evolved government
Restoration in Northern Ireland we've
been here before
oh we have yes we have another uh
deadline another deadline Miss but let
me try and strike a positive and an
optimistic note because uh although we
are disgracefully eight months out from
elections with no executive no
functioning uh assembly
um all at the behest of the dup the
Democratic unionist party I have to say
at times assisted by the Tory government
but eight months on there is now an
urgent and pressing need for government
to be re-established and there is now
finally a sense of movement finally a
sense that a reasonable rational
approach can be taken and a deal can be
struck on the outstanding issues around
the protocol that those matters can be
resolved that we can then get back to
work and we can get people elected by
the way and paid through the public
purse back to work and delivering for
people as the Health crisis rooms in the
the grip of a cost of living crisis is
not too much for people in the north of
Ireland to expect that when they go out
and they vote and they return their
Democratic verdict that the political
people political leaders get back to
work so I'm optimistic in as much as
um Mr cleverly is in Washington there's
been a flurry of the foreign secretary
there's been a flurry of activity and
meetings progress has been made progress
was made more than a year ago on the
issue of medicine Supply we've resolved
the issue on Veterinary medicines issues
around data sharing that the British
government have had been really put up a
blockade on that matter it seems to be
resolved so if the truth is okay with
Goodwill and with a determination to get
this job done actually a deal can be
done and it can be done very quickly and
I would just like to urge everybody
forget what happens in the past forget
the roadblocks and the ups and the Downs
let's get this done let's land on a fair
and reasonable conclusion ensured the
smooth operation of the protocol and
then for goodness sake people need to
get back to work because in the end
another election if that is what happens
and the rule book says if we don't have
the institutions we have to go to an
election but thus far all we have had is
stalemate and a sense of limbo and
that's not a good place for us today for
that end isn't it time the EU stop using
Northern Ireland to punish the UK and
and accept
its constitutional position as an
integral part of the United Kingdom it's
been seven years nearly since the UK
voted and Northern ire voted not to be
part of the European Union anymore so
the north of Ireland didn't vote not to
be part of the European Union part of
the United
people in the north voted to remain and
just be very clear
that it was deeply deeply unsettling for
the entire island of Ireland this brexit
and by the way I respect by the way the
right of people in England across
Britain to say we no longer wish to be
part of the European Union that is
absolutely your prerogative and I would
not wish to intrude on that but I do
have to remind you that that decision
had very very far-reaching implications
for where I live and for my country
um and I I have to say that that reality
was not recognized in in my view in the
course of the entire brexit debate and
then only very belatedly after the fact
the penny dropped well actually Ireland
the island of Ireland is a single
landmass
um we have a peace process to the credit
of everybody that has been painstakingly
built now over a decades we're 25 years
a quarter of a century K of the Good
Friday agreement in peace and that the
brexit uh phenomenon could not overturn
upturn upend all of of that no
responsible person would wish to have
that so I don't believe and I do not
accept for a second that the European
anybody in Europe has used the north to
punish anyone I think we have all simply
recognized our reality that in order for
Britain uh having taken its decision the
realities of that come home to roost on
the island of Ireland and then we have
to ask how do we keep the lights on on
our Island how do we protect the peace
how do we protect the all-ireland
economy how do we protect people's job
prospects their their standard of living
and that's responsible work I think and
I think the challenge is I would cast
differently I think the challenge has
proven
to convince the British government not
to act unilaterally
to convince the British government that
it is not a good look for them to
announce to the world that they will
trash and break international law to
convince the British government that
when you land on an agreement and bear
in mind this protocol was negotiated and
agreed by a British government when you
sign on for something like that you
honor your word and I only hope and I
really hope that we are now at a point
where where a good faith productive
negotiation will now ensue as quickly as
as possible and that we will have a
positive outcome
um your um Deputy Michelle O'Neill
um first Minister designate I think I'm
right instead that's correct
um Shin Fein stands on the brink of
History could hold power in both the
North and the South of Ireland
doesn't that instill some hope in trying
to look for a compromise doesn't that
isn't that watching fan should be
looking at just over the horizon you
could be in charge of both parts of
Ireland
we could be and of course that's that's
in the gift of the Irish electors but
yes Michelle last uh May was a very
historic election in the north of
Ireland the island as you know has been
partitioned now for more than a century
as as part of the the colonial Retreat
of Britain we were uh colonized as you
know we we got the sharp ends of British
imperialism that's probably for another
conversation and another a day but the
the election in May was significant
because For the First Time an Irish
Republican and Irish nationalist emerges
as first minister in a political
jurisdiction that was designed a century
ago for that to never ever happen so
that's I think more than anything
crystallized the extent of political
change and aren't in a really positive
way I think it said not just to
Republicans and nationalists that things
had equaled up but it says to everybody
no jobs Beyond you you know no position
even the highest position in the north
of Ireland and similarly in the South
now you shouldn't pain the party is
performing well polling well I hope that
we will be in the next government it is
my ambition that we would lead the next
government in Dublin all of that is
positive emblematic of really positive
Progressive change
um in Ireland and and look ensuring that
the peace process that the Good Friday
agreement is implemented that the
institutions work for everyone is part
and parcel of that change so on the
issue of compromise K from from the
get-go
everybody and the negotiation is between
the the British government and the
European institutions
and the European institutions made clear
we are up for a deal let's hear what the
concerns are what does that deal need to
look like though I mean you know you I
think the shape of it was talking about
Northern Ireland and the southern part
of the island you are in a position as I
said where it's just on the horizon
where you could be in charge of both
yeah
what does a deal have to look like for
you
well the the deal in relation to the
protocol
um I I think it has to deal with the
issue of concerns around overly
burdensome checks between Britain and
the north it has to deal with the
administrative burden these are issues
that have been raised these are issues
that are amenable to Solutions I think
we're very close to the remember a
majority of people elected in the north
of Ireland support the protocol people
in business will say to you here are the
difficulties here are the pinch points
but everybody accepts that the protocol
needs to be finessed but we need the
protocol
um as a consequence of brexit so in that
respect that steel I think the Contours
of that act at this point are actually
very clear it's a question of cracking
on and getting the job done the Deep he
won't agree with this border down the
Irish sea Wellness well look
um the dup have their View they are they
express their their view of things their
concerns
and that's fine
there are other reviews
um they do not represent the majority
view in the north of Ireland and I'm not
taking from their Democratic right to
express their views well we need
everybody back in storm and what we need
is an acceptance that for power sharing
to work you have to be prepared to share
Power by a definition we also need a
democratic acceptance that in order for
government to work for democracy to work
you have to come at things in a
reasonable frame of mind and it can't be
a case of my way or the highway that's
not fair and I I would challenge the dup
in in this regard I mean so many
important things that really matter in
people's day-to-day lives have either
been delayed or haven't happened at all
because we don't have government in the
north and I would also say this to them
if their view is that they can crush the
institutions of the Good Friday
agreement in the hope of a return to
direct rule from London London that is
not in Prospect that is not an option
I'd always remind them that there's many
parties and many interests at play in
terms of all of this obviously the
British government the Irish government
our European colleagues but also people
across the water in in the United States
of America and beyond all of whom have
an interest in Good Will towards and
skin in the game when it comes to
maintaining peace and progress in
Ireland finally Ireland's Deputy Michael
Martin and other ministers hosting talks
with the Northern Ireland secretary
Chris Heaton Harris today has your party
been invited
well this is a a governmental meeting
it's the intergovernmental conference
it's for those who who lead government
so so no we haven't but there wouldn't
be anything uh hugely unusual uh in that
different Ministers of government are
amazing and that's a good thing so let
me welcome that however we need to now
ratchet this up to the level of prime
minister and taishak the Irish station
the leader of the Dublin government we
really need care and caution we also
need a sense of ambition and drive to
get things back up and moving and
working again we've talked here okay
about the the institution of government
in Belfast the executive the assembly
which needs to get up get cracking and
get back to work but there's also north
south bodies that operate across the
island there's East-West relationships
between Ireland and Britain all of those
now need to be really really carefully
um cared for and put back on a really
active footing because you see in the
end my ambitions for Irish you know I'm
an Irish Republican I believe
reunification of our Island Ascension is
the best opportunity for all of us you
know this this is our and I feel hugely
optimistic about that I think it's an
opportunity of a lifetime but well
that's okay they're unionist and they'll
make their case for the maintenance uh
of of the the union
um all of these opportunities are ahead
of us and I know the only way that we
can fully grasp those is by listening to
each other working together and
accepting in the end that the Irish
people are sovereign that we have a
right to determine our future and we
will do that we will do that together
and that's the bigger picture like the
news from Ireland I'm conscious very
often on your program it's about
stalemate it's about oh my God no
they're dead so we're giving you a good
chunk of time so you can make your
points eloquently as you are
um if you were t-shock and many people
think you will be the next one what
would you be saying to the EU right now
what I'm saying to them now at this
point I would be saying continue to work
hard
continued to engage
get the job done get the job done for us
and I I mean I have said the same to
your government I've said that the same
to
um British governments you know engage
in good faith engage and recognize that
when all of the Diplomatic high wire act
subsides you know when the the
television cameras are turned off and
everybody goes home there are real
communities real families real people
who rely on the stability of the peace
process the advancement of the peace
process don't play games with that do
not play games with that and I I was
very heartened to see that the the
leader of the the British labor price
the leader of the opposition here
asserting again curious armor asserting
again the labor party like it's in
Northern Ireland in terms of that's
right in Belfast asserting you know
their contribution which was very
considerable at the time defining in the
building of the peace process and this
has been a collective average and I
would just urge everybody to reflect on
that I mean we're all in politics and
some politics can be it's as we would
call it senior hurling you know it's it
can be a tough game it can be sometimes
quite a you know an adversarial uh
Enterprise but but there are moments
where collaboration where respect for
inclusion
are the big ticket items this is one of
them so let's get it done so I'd urge
the British government get this done no
more unilateral action get it done we
need it done